Film Courage: …Here is this lovely bag [hands
Justin the bag with questions in it]
Justin Warren, Filmmaker of THEN THERE WAS
JOE: Awesome.
I will just pick one at random.
Film Courage: By the way, where can we purchase
this bag?
Justin: It’s on my website.
Just kidding…it’s my wife’s make-up
bag.
[Reads question from bag] This is from Andrey
Savchenko…I’m sorry, I’m sorry, I know
I’ve butchered your name but I appreciate
your question.
“Hi, what’s the biggest obstacle on your
way in the whole process and how you were
able to get through it?
Thank you, Andy?”
Thank you for your question.
What’s my biggest obstacle on my way in
the whole process and how were you able to
get through it?
Surprisingly I think for me in my feature
film I think the biggest obstacle was really
just fear.
That might sound like a cop-out answer but
it’s not.
I think the hardest part is trusting yourself
throughout the madness of everything that
is going on.
One of the biggest fears I had was just trying
to come up with the money for it because that
was a really difficult process.
We did a Kickstarter campaign and we raised
$35,000 for it which I think I had a little
bit of beginner’s luck because when I look
back at it now I can’t believe that we did
that, it’s pretty wild.
But I think that the hardest part it’s really
the fear and the patience it takes to sort
of do one of these things because things are
never going to move as fast as you want them
to move.
One of the things I realized is almost everything
that I thought “Yeah…I should have that
done in a month.”
I just started multiplying it by four.
So that should be done in a month and we take
four months.
Working at this level (because my film is
a micro-budget film) it’s basically there’s
like that triangle, the good, fast and cheap
triangle.
You can only have two of them.
That is totally a real thing.
And so if you don’t have the money to do
something and you are having someone work
on it, they’re probably only going to work
on it when they have time to do so.
And that means that you can get it good but
it’s not going to be fast.
I noticed that because I think we did really,
really great work on my film and the people
(all the different disciplines) did a great
job but it took a really long time and I think
that the patience can almost be enough to
drive you mad.
For instance our VFX guy who is a brilliant
VFX artist and he works at this big VFX house
was basically working on my film at nights
every other weekend because he had stuff to
do and he just had a brand-new kid and things
like that.
So that took a long time.
My dear friend who is a sound designer did
sound on my film but he was working on that
throughout all his different jobs so that
was a super slow process.
I think just being prepared with patience
(how long it’s going to take) you’d be
surprised.
Waiting for something can drive you mad especially
if that is your number one focus which is
your feature or your project that you’re
working on because it’s only going to burn
with that level of intensity to you the creator.
It’s not going to burn with that level of
intensity to anybody else.
And knowing that and embracing that can allow
you to be cool with it.
I think earlier with the post-production process
I didn’t understand that and I would get
angry and I would get very impatient and I
would get confused like “Why aren’t they
getting back to me?
What’s going on?
Huh?
I can’t take it!”
Which is just silly because the reality is
anything that is good takes time.
I think the quote is from Alice in Wonderland
but ‘There Are No Shortcuts To Places Worth
Going.’
That’s a real thing.
We live in a culture where we want things
and we want it now and we want things instantly.
But when it comes to making something like
a feature or just any long-term project it
just takes time.
And it takes time for the thing to develop,
it takes time for the thing to marinate and
the patience and getting through the fear
of it are the two biggest obstacles I’d
say.